club what i can exclusively reveal this
morning is that sir lewis hamilton the
seven times formula one world champion
and serena williams the 23 times uh
grand slam tournament winner
have agreed to back one of the remaining
three bidders for chelsea now
the two sports stars have uh committed
to spending as i understand it 10
million pounds each of their own money
on the bid for chelsea that's being
spearheaded by
sir martin broughton the former british
airways and liverpool chairman now just
to recap that consortium is spearheaded
by sir martin but it also includes lord
coe
the former british olympian the
american sports investment group harris
blitzer sports and entertainment which
owns a number of uh sports
uh teams in the us and also has a
minority stake in crystal palace which
of course they will need to sell if they
are successful in their bid
for chelsea under premier
league rules but the involvement of sir
lewis hamilton and serena williams in
this consortium
is both notable and surprising not least
surprising ian because sir lewis is a
a self-declared arsenal
fan but as i understand it they have
been
attracted to this bid for chelsea by its
focus on
diversity uh it's got a globally diverse
group of investors and so lewis as i
understand it would be involved heavily
in chelsea's future efforts to combat uh
discrimination if this bid is successful
now in terms of the process uh final
bids for chelsea were submitted uh a
week ago
to reign group the merchant bank that's
overseeing uh the auction on behalf of
roman abramovich and as i understand it
a preferred bidder is likely to be
selected by the end of this month
three bidders remaining this consortium
that uh sir lewis hamilton and serena
williams have joined
the one that is headed by steve palucca
and larry tanenbaum two
north american billionaires with
significant expertise in owning
sports assets and then the third bidder
is the one that is fronted by uh todd
bowley the la dodgers part owner but
which also includes significant
financial commitment from clear lake
capital and genuinely in i think it's
too close to call
it's going to be very interesting to see
whether the emergence of
sir lewis hamilton and serena williams
as investors in the bid
led by sir martin broughton
is a telling factor when rain makes its
decision in the coming days